and i suspect that communism originally
was not a utopia i think that's in the
same way as original christianity it had
a particular kind of vision
and this vision is a society a mode of
organization within the society in which
humans can
ex coexist at scale without coercion
the same way as we do in a healthy
family right in a good family you don't
terrorize each other into compliance but
you understand what everybody needs and
what everybody can is able to contribute
and what the intended future of the
whole thing is and you
everybody coordinates their behavior in
the right way and informs each other
about how to do this and all the
interactions that happen are
instrumental to making that happen
right
could this happen at scale and i think
this is the idea of communism communism
is opposed to the idea that we need
economic terror or other forms of terror
to make that happen but in practice what
happened is that the
proto-communist countries the real
existing socialism replaced a part of
the economic terror with moral terror
right so we were told to do the right
thing for moral reasons and of course it
didn't really work and the economy
eventually collapsed and the immoral
terror had actual real cost right people
were in prison because they were morally
non-compliant
and
that is
the other thing is that the idea of
communism became a utopia so it
basically was projected to the afterlife
we were told in in my childhood that
communism was a hypothetical society to
which we were in a permanent revolution
that justified everything that was
presently wrong with society morally but
it was something that our grandchildren
probably would not ever see because it
was too ideal and too far in the future
to make it happen right now and people
were just not there yet morally
and the same thing happened with
christianity right this notion of heaven
was mythologized and projected into an
afterlife and i think this was just the
idea of god's kingdom of this world in
which we instantiate the next level
transcendental agent in the perfect form
so everything goes smoothly and without
violence and without conflict and
without this human messiness on this
economic messiness and the terror and
coercion that existed in the present
societies
and the idea of that the humans can
exist at scale in a harmonious way
non-coercively it's untested
a lot of people tested it but didn't get
it to work so far
and the utopia is a world in where you
get all the good things without any of
the bad things
and you are i think very susceptible to
believe in utopias when you are very
young and don't understand that
everything has to happen in causal
patterns that there is always feedback
loops that ultimately are closed there's
nothing that just happens because it's
good or bad good or bad don't exist in
isolation they only exist with respect
to larger systems
so
can you intuit why utopias fail as
as systems
so like having a utopia that's out there
beyond the horizon is it because then
um
it's not only because it's impossible to
achieve utopias but it's because
what certain humans certain small number
of humans start
to uh um
sort of greedily
attain power and money and control and
influence
as they
become uh
as they see the power in uh using this
uh
idea of a utopia
saying why is my garden not perfect it's
because some evil weeds are overgrowing
it and they always do yeah right but
this is not how it works a good garden
is a system that is in balance and
requires minimal interactions by the
gardener
and
so you need to create a system that is
designed to self stabilize and the
design of social systems requires not
just the implementation of the desired
functionality but the next level design
but also in biological systems you need
to create a system that wants to
converge to the intended function
right so instead of just creating an
institution like the fda that is
performing a particular kind of rule a
role in society you need to make sure
that the fda is actually driven by a
system that wants to do this optimally
that is incentivize the root optimally
and then makes the performance that is
actually enacted in every generation
instrumental to that thing that actual
goal right and that is much harder to
design and to achieve so you have to
design a system where
i mean listen communism also was quote
unquote incentivized
to be a
feedback loop
system that achieves that utopia it's
just it wasn't working given human
naturally the incentives were not
correct yes
how do you uh
incentivize people when they are getting
coal off the ground to work as hard as
possible because it's a terrible job and
it's very bad for your health and
right how do you do this and you can uh
give them prices and medals and status
to some degree right there's only so
much status to give for that and most
people will not fall for this yeah right
or you can pay them
or uh and you probably have to pay them
in an asymmetric way because if you pay
everybody the same and they uh
you nationalize the coal mines
eventually people will figure out that
they can game the system yes so you're
you're describing capitalism
so capitalism is the present solution to
the system and what we also noticed that
i think that marx was correct in saying
that capitalism is prone to crisis that
capitalism is a system that in its
dynamics is not convergent but divergent
it's not a stable system
and that eventually it produces an
enormous
potential for productivity
but it also is systematically
misallocating resources so a lot of
people cannot participate
in the production and consumption
anymore and this is what we observe we
observe that the middle class in the u.s
is tiny
it's a lot of people think that they're
middle class but if you are still flying
economy you're not middle class
right
every class is a magnitude
and
[Laughter]
is really like airline classes
a lot of people are economy have we
really business class and very few are
first class and some are widget i mean
some i i understand i i i think there's
uh yeah
maybe some people
probably i would push back against that
definition of the middle class it does
feel like the middle class is pretty
large but yes there's a discrepancy in
terms of wealth
um so there's a big gap in terms of the
productivity that our society could have
yeah there is no reason for anybody to
fly economy right we would be able to
let everybody travel in style
well but also some people like to be
frugal even when they're billionaires
okay so like that
let's take that yes but uh i mean you
probably don't need to be traveling
lavish but
you also don't need to be tortured right
there is a difference between frugal and
uh subjecting yourself to fortune listen
i love economy i don't understand why
you're comparing a flying economy to
torture
you